what's goody hop breath the verse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I
am your host comedian Joel buers and our
guest today is one of the most
charitable comics in the game at one
time in his career he won a 100 Grand on
Star Search and donated half of it to
help out the homeless been trying to get
that back every
s but his Underdog Story actually
started in Chicago living in a one
bedroom with seven family members
detainment career started as a street
performer in Chicago where shortly after
he sold all his belongings moved to
California where he was doing up to five
1hour shows a day performing on the
beaches of
Venice all that hustle all that hard
work paid off as he got discovered while
doing these Street shows to where he got
to work with Incredible people like
Eddie Murphy Bernie Mack Martin Lawrence
and now hot breath ladies and gentlemen
hot breath and sister welcome to the hot
breath of verse Mr Michael
call wait a minute I'm looking down here
I'm trying to
see where the hell you where's your um
you didn't read that no that's that's
you're not reading that no that's off
the Dome fam and you like 100 you was
right on it you ain't messed up with
nothing no no I kept looking over there
to see what the hell is the Kyro okay
all right all right you're you're
excellent already than you for welcome
me me to this fabulous show hey you know
we ain't new to this we grew to this oh
okay you True to this come on player
little ATL slang type of thing I love it
I don't know why I'm code switching
right off the jum here but it it is it
is amazing that we're doing this this is
literally the first time we're doing
this in this studio space so I
appreciate you this is a virgin
experience and I'm happy to be the one
to break you in go ahead well weren't
you the first uh like black late night
host as well I think I was I'm trying to
see if anybody came before that I don't
thinks I think ours was first I think it
was before Vibe I think Vibe came right
after us but on BET we had a show called
B live from La yeah I think I was the
first to do that certainly the first
black L KN show host that's for sure but
I keep thinking maybe maybe Chris
Spencer when he did Vibe maybe that was
right before us but I'm not certain on
that you know I'm I just just with Chris
the other night great comedian hey I'm
your boy Michael KY world famous world
renowned off talked about alleged
comedian gentleman and a scholar
intellectual Giant in the pool of mental
midgets and a connoisseur of fine
habida ignore this chicken because they
don't have nothing to do with
it yeah you you are a bit of a Wordsmith
you do like to play around with words a
lot I love words man yeah I love words
man you know but I was wearing my pink
today for Barbie I haven't seen the
movie yet but everybody seem to be going
Barbie crazy
so my chicken loves her and we said well
we go to check it out see what's up my
co-host on my morning show show she is a
Barbie file she knows everything about
Barbie when she is a child she got one
of the first black Barbie dos and she
still has it to this day you know she's
when the movie came out she almost
fainted just going to it cuz she's like
ha and I kept saying [__] you black I'm
sorry what kind of show I'm sorry this a
family show can we curse no you're good
okay all right all right go ahead
Reverend over there was staring at me
like I did something wrong sorry re
what's the story with the chicken I've
seen you you carried around a lot what's
oh it's no story it's just fun how long
you been doing that I think I've had
this about two years my ex gave me this
chicken and it's very funny because you
know I sort of we sort of broke up
because she vegan are you vegan mm okay
cuz she vegan and I'm I'm not I like
animals I love chicken and she's a
brutal vegan like I I'll be eating
chicken she'd be like oh I see you're
eating caucus today and be like yeah and
I'm putting some barbecue sauce on this
carcus too [__] anyway um so yes I
every place I take it people who never
laugh Never
Smile they smile cuz they're confounded
you know what is this grown ass black
man clearly fly doing with a rubber
chicken well it's just fun that's what I
was asking and I mean this chicken has
power you don't even understand around
the country there are women who walk up
to me and try to impersonate the chicken
what they come up and say Mr Kai I can
do the chicken and I said [__] do the
chicken yes I can do wait wait a minute
wait a minute about choke I can show you
wait oh no I've choked this chicken many
a night Sir we're not going get on that
topic we'll be here for a minute um
pause pause wait I know he over there
with the seven minute uh 7c pause Buton
when I say that but do the what pict on
camera I'm going show one the people on
the camera the middle one okay before
but she turned her face we didn't get to
see all see are you ready here we
go you don't understand the power the
chicken brother you know I'm telling you
it's crazy and and you know I be places
where people don't even speak to black
people and then I'll squeeze that
chicken and you'll see a look and then
sometime they're irritated what you
doing with that chicken you know and
then I'll do it
again now sit it down and they'll come
up Sir what is it with the chicken I
said ma'am there's nothing with the
chicken and they laugh and walk away and
they haven't laughed in a long time this
this the that's man that's a that's a
tension breaker right there that must
have been you you've been able to
entertain everyone doing the street
performing so you must have just picked
up on all sorts of little cues to be
able to just get people's attention and
then hold it well you know street
performing really really trained me as a
comedian um one thing is yes definitely
get their attention because you got to
stop people then people don't come to
the beach uh to find you they come to
the beach to get some cheap pizza and
wear t-shirts with the uh you know for
four t-shirts for $10 and to see the
girls in the bikinis you know that's why
you can go to Venice Beach or most
beaches with 20 or $30 and have a good
time you know we sort of like something
they stumble on they sort of walking
down the boardwalk and they see a crowd
and they go over and see what's going
over so you so what's going on so you
sort of have to draw them like me I
would start My Show by Gathering five or
six people and having them trick
everybody else say look we going do
trick uh when I get three I want y'all
to go crazy scream cheer whistle rap
ladies throw your underwear in the air
and the people down the street going to
think some big [__] going on and they
gonna run over here and so I would count
the three and they would go crazy
because people want to be part of the
game so they yay they screaming stuff
and you could just see people running so
now the people who are standing there
are laughing their butt off because the
trick worked so now we got a whole bunch
of suckers that added on to the people
who started it so now we laugh together
about how we tricked them while we doing
that more people are being gathered to
it and then we start the show so I mean
I would do for 9 years from 86 to 95 I
would do five one hour shows every
Saturday and Sunday and I was killing
them six figures a year baby I was
killing them and that was weekends only
two days a week two days a week six
figures yeah but I did put in 10 hours
so that's a lot of work and and it was
not just because it started out as
change like changeing dollars and stuff
and then this dirty grungy old white
dude came to me and gave me a piece that
changed everything he said you know they
want to call black people colored he
said but black people color always the
same when they born they Brown when they
die they Brown when they made they brown
white people when they born they pink
when they cold they blue when they mad
they red when they die they gray they
your colored people and it blew my mind
cuz this guy had a little sack with
everything on in it he was all grungy I
gave him a couple of dollars and then I
took that and turned it into this
routine called the basic colored
people's routine and so I would start My
Show by joking with every race I saw in
the audience what what the Mexicans oh
there you are okay I knew it had to be
some bus boys or something oh there they
are Mexican where you get them oranges
you know and so they laugh about the
fact they always have oranges I talk
about black people's hair the different
hairstyles I talk about white people
being scared of black people you say
white lady with a black purse she be
skipping I don't see no [__] so I
would joke about every racial group I
was we have any knes any needes in
audience knes Japanese Chinese you know
needes and I would just mess with every
group and then I would say I joke about
racism because racism is a joke you know
what I'm saying we around here judging
people because they look different from
us that's somebody else controlling us
we got to learn to live live together
and love together and and it became the
biggest piece I had out there because
folks could come and see reality and
they could laugh and it made so much
money I mean all of a sudden people
weren't giving me coins and dollars and
[__] you know it's giving me 20s and 50s
and hundreds and people gave me watches
I got the first year I got 13 watches
and like 19 gold chains people give me
things because I wasn't just tickling
their funny bone I was making them think
and feel as well as laugh and so I
started adding more and more conscious
pieces so I would do the piece about my
addiction because I'm an addict so I did
crack for 23 years and now I have 12
years of sobriety but I was out there
high I was high when I wasn't working
but I was still out there talking about
my addiction or I was still addicted but
I was talking about it in such a way to
heal other people you know and let
people know that you can't stop that you
can't turn it around yet I hadn't turned
it around yet while I was out there I
finally turned it around from preaching
it talking about it laughing about it I
ended up doing it which actually made me
sober as well so now I do um a oneman
show that I'm doing in 100 cities called
Michael kya's mama and it's an hour and
a half I play 17 characters so I play my
mother my father I play me four ages my
four big brothers the alcoholics the
crackheads and the church ladies that
ran my community and so I do a 90minut
show and I tell the whole story about my
addiction and my recovery you know kind
of stuff I had to do when I was out
there kind of stuff I did do when out
there and what it does is really heals
people as well as tickles their funny
bones and it tells my journey from
coming from the projects of Chicago to
Hollywood and turn it around so it works
for me and it really tells the story too
that anybody can do it you know I mean
if you come from where I've come from
and you did drugs for 20 years if you
can turn around and be smack dab in the
middle of your dream that's where I am
I'm smack dab in the middle of my dream
right now I'm doing everything I've ever
dreamed I wanted to do you know I have a
Morning Show five days a week week on
YouTube the Michael CER Morning Show now
I I've only done 687 so I understand if
you haven't heard about it but I do that
five days a week Monday through Friday
on the YouTube I do it uh 7: am which is
Pacific Standard time which is La that's
9:00 am Central Time Chicago uh 10:00
a.m eastern time New York right so I do
the show every show we have a comedian
I've already put on 518 comedians out of
the 600 something shows CU some people
come back bring back again we do a
comedian every day we sing We have a
vocalist come on almost every day with a
poet every day we talk to somebody
interesting from the community and we
pray every show and we laugh so if you
want to get up in the morning and laugh
and pray to start your day that's why II
designed this show because I designed it
in the middle of coid When people's
already mad enough but then they had
this fool Hitler's first cousin uh Trump
uh out there stirring up and rabble
rousing all through the community making
people think it's okay to be racist
again it's okay to be a hater again it's
okay to treat people poorly he stirred
up this whole energy well now people are
bolder about being racist and you still
used to be polite about it you know we
knew it's [__] racist but at least
they wouldn't stand on the on the on the
ground about it they G about their
business leave me alone leave you alone
it's not like that now so now people are
fighting everywhere people hungry
everywhere coid hit so I want to put
together a show where people can come
and laugh and pray to start their day
because your day always ends the way it
begins I mean you get up and you kick
your foot on something God damn it I
keep telling y'all I don't put no chairs
in the middle of every time I tell y'all
you you start your day complaining your
whole day going to be complaining you
going to be fussing with people all day
I swear I guarantee you you going to be
late in the afternoon you gonna find
something wrong with somebody but if you
start your day positive look in the
mirror remind yourself of how great you
are God created you he don't create No
Junk look at you fly your good hair yeah
I remember having hair I mean I I loved
it it went down to your face oh my God
it shifted down I had a huge afro and
everything but we have so many blessings
so if we get up in the morning and look
in the mirror and talk to God and than
him for what we got already that's a
power day you spend the rest of your day
with joy and energy and light you know
squeeze the
chicken but if if you get up complaining
it's the other way so that's why we
built that show and then over the three
years we've been doing it so many
comedians have come in so many actors
motivational speakers doctors uh
holistic practitioners so it's just a
cool fly way to start your morning so I
do that on YouTube five days a week
three days a week I have my podcast on
iHeart it's called Michael talks to air
body not everybody everybody e r r b o d
y my first uh guest was a transsexual
named TS Madison she's awesome she had
she's the first transsexual to have her
own network television show she's on she
was on Wii just talking about her life
as a transexual her mama's on there with
her the whole thing and it was really
pretty flat it was it was really flat
and how she carries herself is really
really great because she's proud of who
she is and we have to be that no matter
who or what we are on the planet you got
to own you are and stand true to it no
matter what other people say you know
what I'm saying I mean because me anyway
I got a weird philosophy My Philosophy
is you if you love me I love you and if
you don't like me [__] you too I don't
like no gray area I'm either this or I'm
that it's no in between I don't need
people guessing and wondering so when
you figure out what you are you have to
stand tall in that we have some of the
greatest people they come on and that's
just a podcast Michael talks to
everybody so I do three a day I mean
three a week every week 50 weeks at a
time for the next three years you know
so those are the main things we do the
main stuff I do so when I'm doing the
play I'm talking about the stuff that
I'm doing but I'm talking about my life
I'm talking about my journey and how we
came from living we live before the
projects so we was pre- Project projects
for us was a step up wow you know we
didn't think of as as uh we thought of a
highrise how as buildings we didn't
thinking about as projects cuz they
weren't even projects we moved in there
like 62 and and they were just buildings
determin in projects as we live there
all the gang bangers and the graffiti on
the wall all that stuff but we came from
you know we was pretty poor but we
didn't know it because we happy if you
happy and you got a family you don't
give a damn about money somebody has to
come tell you that that stuff means
something you know what I'm saying so it
I tell the story so we just went and did
it in August last August at the national
black theater Festival so Ben verine
came to the show and saw it he loved it
he came back again loved it so he's
helping me prepare it to take it to
Broadway but it's a cold cold piece but
it's so powerful when I took it to
Chicago I did it at the black Museum uh
the the duaba Museum of African-American
history in Chicago where I'm from one
senator they give me
$5,000 to buy tickets for addicts who
couldn't afford the tickets so they can
come to the show and be inspired so I
sort of think that what we do as
comedians is really a service and I
think also that all humans are put on
this planet to serve and we serve in
different ways we help people other in
different ways uh the gift that I have
is comedy the gift that you have it's
comedy and that is healing literally
People's Health have changed because
their sense of humor um there was a
doctor at
UCLA
ah I can't believe I can't
think I can't think his name's on the
tip of my tongue this dude had cancer
they said you got six months to live
first thing he did is got out the
hospital he said you don't be in the
hospital everybody in here sick so
instead he moved into a fancy um Suite
in one of the finest hotels in the city
because it was cheaper than a day at the
hospital so instead of trying to heal in
a hospital full of sick people who going
to come in all night and try to give you
pills and medicines CU it's their job to
sell that to you he went to his a hotel
and then he got a big screen TV that's
one they had remember the box TVs they
sit on the ground they was huge he got
one of those put in his room and all he
did is watch Comedy brother day and
night Heckle and Jackal Laura and Hardy
the three stoes uh the Marx Brothers if
you name it uh he back to back and and
in and ingested vitamin C he ate oranges
he drank orange juice anything with
vitamin C that's all he did his name is
Norman Cousins Dr Norman Cousins and if
you just go online and put in the doctor
who saved his life with orange juice and
laughter it'll pop up and so well he
died anyway but that was until seven
years later and by then he was one of
the top professors at UCLA and had
written seven books on how to heal
yourself through laughter and vitamin C
so laughter has been proven scientific
specifically to be healing and in our
society when everybody mad at everybody
like you go to airport people ain't even
smiling no more I used to go to airport
people are so happy to be at the airport
people was holding hands people was
laughing everybody is tense everywhere
if you don't laugh you don't [__] around
have to punch somebody in their face so
we are healing people every time we make
somebody laugh every time I squeeze that
chicken it changes a life you may not
realize it but it's somebody who ain't
had a good day at all and then he see
this food over here with a damn pink
chicken squeezing the in middle of
everybody and I I I my favorite
restaurant for breakfast I have to say
this crack a barrel now at first I
wasn't going to restaurant what you call
me that's what I'm saying at first I
wasn't going to go to the restaurant
called Cracker bear I grew up in the
projects in Chicago the Southside Rober
tell home 4352 South State par 909 and
where I come from we don't [__] around
with no crackers and a barrel full of
crackers that's a whole lot of crackers
so I wasn't even go no damn Cracker
Barrel but Cracker Barrel is my favorite
breakfast spot but I go to Cracker
Barrel once we went and there was a old
look like a c mudgin old grumpy little
white dude in overall sitting right over
that table and you know me me and my
black friends and we laugh at I'm
squeezing the chicken and he whipped
around and just gave me the ugliest look
when I squeezed the first time then he
looked back in curiosity but he hadn't
started smiling yet but I just kept
messing with the chick sometime I just
squeeze it slow like
this now he already bugged by it now I'm
squeezing and then we can see his body
side a hunch like this
we could tell his ass was laughing
though his back was to us so I hit him
with a couple more and then we ain't
think about it no more and that old
white dude got up took one step forward
turned around and came back and said you
made my whole day today and he walked
out the place I'm telling you brother
it's just because you don't see it com
what is humor anyway humor is the
opposite humor is a contra humor is a
contradiction of what you see coming you
don't see that [__] coming you don't see
that especially you don't see it coming
from fly ass brother you barely see me
without a suit people didn't even know I
own jeans when you see me I'm suited and
booted with a damn orange chicken I got
16 chickens orange yellow one is tie dye
not to be confused with rainbow
different
connotation I'm sorry no where where did
you even like who did you learn this
mindset of like abundance and service
from coming up in like you know you said
you pre- projects in Chicago where didd
you learn this I'm a member of the
greatest Church in the whole wide world
it's called Agape they don't even call
it a church they call Ag Agape
International Center of faith in Los
Angeles I did Agape night at a church
perform there agape love right yes a
gape love all encompassing love my
minister is Michael Beckwith but I have
many spiritual leaders but Michael
beckworth is is my Minister for that
that particular church and that's all he
teaches and all he teaches is he's a
great teacher of the truth he funny as
hell too he can make a million dollars
year being a stand up Comm he's
hilarious and Michael Beck was just
reminds us and then plus I try to read
all the doctrines you know I've read
everything in talm the Bible uh the
Quran I try to read all of the books you
know and unfortunately I'm not I can't
claim a religion because I'm not
religious I'm more spiritual but I
utilize things from all the doctrines so
I think right now they're calling people
like me um what do they call it when you
pick stuff out um when you only pick out
what you
want that's a word for Where cherry
picker I'm a cherry picker so I'm one of
those people who cherry-pick religion so
it's some stuff in the Hebrew faith that
I can use but I'm not Hebrew but it's
some stuff in the faith that I can use
like like I love love and I'm getting
married November 4th to the greatest
woman in the whole wi World
congratulations but in Hebrew Faith they
have a book called talmud and in talmud
which is a book of laws just like the
Bible it says that God created all
people as perfect halves and that and
it's called your bisher or a man it's
your bisher and when you find your
perfect half you become whole and then
your heart sings a royal song and you
never have to look for love again and
people say well if that's true why there
so many divorces cuz you didn't find
your bashera you settled for some [__]
that was close you know what I'm saying
well she do this and she do that well
she don't do this what I like but she do
do this good okay I'll settle but that
becomes a problem in a lot of
relationships because 10 years later 11
years later the thing you really need
that you know she doesn't give you
starts banging at your door that's when
you get to sneaking and peeking and
going places and doing things you ain't
supposed to do but when you find your
prer you know it because your heart
sings a royal song there's no effort in
it it is easy you know and so with this
queen of mind I found my Basher but
that's one of the pieces that I use from
the Hebrew Faith so I cherry pick like
the Bible for me David and Goliath man I
love that story that's the bomb.com
because when he walk Goliath when little
big David W out big old ugly bad breath
[__] up teeth Goliath when he wore him
out all he had was some smooth stones in
a sling that he had gotten out of the
river and when he went to Goliath he
said I'm [__] you up but it's not
because of who I am it's not because of
who I got but do you see who I'm
standing with see one with God is a
majority so if as long as you have the
spirit with you you can walk through any
door and do anything but you got to own
it for real you got to claim it you got
to know it you can't you can't just
selectively decide I love the Lord today
but not tomorrow you love God you love
God you love Spirit you love Spirit but
everything's about Karma so whatever
you're doing is coming back to you so if
you're loving the universe the universe
is loving you you know if you send out
negative [__] you must sit down and get
ready cuz it's coming to visit you cuz
karma is real and you get it even if you
don't get it but see in my life instead
of trying to work the system of karma
which is a circle that goes round and
around I'm trying to work spiral I don't
think we just go round and around I
think we go around and around and lift
ourselves and every every time we make a
rotation we learn more stuff we get a
little stronger a little braver a little
wiser hopefully otherwise you just
sitting in a circle and ain't nothing
happening for you you know but the
chicken changes all of it you know so I
could have high philosophy on one end
tell jokes on the other end on had a
chicken right in the middle it's just
another one of our wonderful tools but
as comedians we're healing people man
we're we're changing people making
people feel better about themselves and
you could teach any lesson you want to
teach as long as you wrap it up with a
joke that's why when I was on Venice the
first piece after the color people's
routine was about safe sex CU people was
dying of AIDS this was 1986 and in ' 86
you could not buy airspace on radio or
TV for
condoms they said it was dirty they
wern't selling condoms and all you need
was a [__] condom to save your life
but they wouldn't advertise them so I'm
on the beach joking about them because
you know with the condom I had a uh
sixpack uh sixpack uh eight pack and
12pack so the sixpack is for the
Hispanic brothers that's for making love
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday but off on Sunday okay eight
pack that's the black brothers that's
what makeing love Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday and
twice on Sunday and then of course the
12 pack that was for the white dudes
that's January February March so if you
do do something like that to someone
who's in the audience who's dealing with
a situation that's broken their heart
because of where they are sexually or
with their then it opens it it calms
them down it opens them up for you to
slide in the knowledge I remember one
show a lesbian lady came to me
afterwards and said my lover died six
months ago from AIDS and I never thought
I'd laugh again and you just made me
laugh about condoms so if we can get
into to their head through the humor
then we can open it up and slide in
information so what I try to do is
conscious comedy I try to make you think
and feel as well as laugh but my stuff
going to be have plenty of jokes and a
lot of them old jokes I don't think a
old joke should die just CA the
[__] that wrote it did he can't
use it no more red fox created 75 comedy
albums dude red fox red is dead he can't
use them jokes no more we supposed to
throw away 75 albums worth a brilliant
joke hell no I tell them to you you tell
them at work you're a hero and you pay
no royalty but see some people steal I
don't Ste I borrow yeah I let the
audience know the [__] ain't mine I said
oh joke alert you know the [__] ain't
mine I heard it somewhere and I'm here
to share it with you just like the other
day I was accused of fat shaming now
I've never made fun of people because of
their weight and I don't know what
they're talking about I I'll tell you
what I said you tell me if this is fat
Shaman okay so this big old fat lady was
on a bike she was on a bike right and
she pading boy she paddling her ass off
right so I yelled out cow she turns to
me and gave me the finger turned back
around and ran right into the [__]
cow nice there I don't think that's that
shame so so so jokes come to me my
friends are come and tell me jokes that
they heard but they can't tell them and
they said Michael you gonna love this
joke you can go back and tell it I can't
tell it I don't know where they got that
joke from I'mma use it though was knock
knocking the door guy open the door he
look around he ain't see nobody he
looked down there's a snail so he just
pick the snail up and threw it as far as
he could M six months later there's a
knocking the door he opened the door
there's a snail snail say now what the
[__] was that all
[Laughter]
about that shit's hilarious somebody
just told me that I don't I didn't know
that but the jokes is what I use to hold
together the material material will deal
with my it'll deal with the racism I've
dealt with it deal with my uh my
addiction and my recovery it deal with
love you know because I'm such in I'm so
in love I'm [__] up I'm I'm a little
[__] I'm in love this girl how' you
meet her
well she was haing on Sunset and I
really needed some coochie no I was in
Winston Salem North Carolina to take my
play to national black theater Festival
and she owns the number one soul food
restaurant in Winston Salem and I
apologize to my mother when I say this
but this woman makes a better salmon
croquet than my mama and my mama's held
that title for 64 years anyway I met her
there and you know when it's real cuz
when it's real it's effortless you ain't
got to work at it it's just everything
feel right you move and Gro I know it's
real because I know longer um I no
longer objectif fight women and I've
objectif fight women my entire life even
when I'm with a woman I see a woman go
by I'm thinking look at that ass check
out them titties wonder if she swallows
you know but now I wouldn't care who you
are I love Rihanna I Love Beyonce but
they could both be standing right here
butt naked with two hands full $100
bills all I can think about is Sonia
that's all I can think about I ain't
never known anything like that never
known love oh I got to tell you my
Stevie Wonder story okay so is this true
this is true okay do nothing but the
truth brother I don't do nothing but the
trth the cow story was true
absolutely so so I went to see
earthquake uh earthquake has a room he
does once a month every third Tuesday
met him on here yeah he's fantastic
every third Tuesday he does a comedy
chatau which I had never heard of it's
in Burbank I've been living in La for 32
years I never heard of so I went to
support my boy you know I ain't there I
wasn't there to perform I'm there to sit
in the Audi so you know I'm in his room
I'm supporting him right and Joe Tor
went up a couple other great Comics went
up Stevie Wonder came in don't worry he
didn't see me okay so uh the comics
would go up and do they stuff and they
was killing they and then they all
stopped and saying happy birthday to
Stevie so I get up to slip out you know
cuz I figure it's over I mean I don't
know how you figure but if you just got
through singing happy birthday to stepen
wonder you might as well roll the
[__] credits it's a rap you know so
I'm trying to leave they grabbed me said
Mr Kai you want to go and do some time I
said I thought it was over they said we
got time for you Mr KY I said Okay cool
so I go up and all I'm talking about is
my baby Sonia I mean she's
so first of all she's fan as frog's hair
you ever seen frog frog you can't see it
it's too goddamn fine okay she's she get
my heart something extra to thob about
man I jump up in the morning without an
alarm clock I'm walking 35% fast she a
bad [__] if I wasn't me I would
have been her so I'm just saying I'm
talking about her I'm doing my whole
piece on my baby and how we about to get
married and the stuff that happened like
one day this how I really know she the
one she's at my house and we done a
Christmas party cuz I just met her last
year so she came to Christmas party and
at day after Christmas party I thought
we had an intruder right cuz I'm going
up to the second floor of my house and
one of those panels are open the thing
you go in to put insulation upair so
it's it's wide open now I've been living
here three and a half years [__]
ain't never been open so I walk into my
room briskly um and she said baby what's
going on I pull out the pistols and I
said I think we have an intruder do you
know how to use a gun and she said no
but give it to me yes sir and we stood
there holding these guns at this hole in
a and cussing the whole out come out
[__] I kill you I kill you Mama
I kill your ancestors you [__]
we nobody in the ho but we didn't know
so we held them guns we called 911 the
police came we gave them a ladder we
hear the guns we gave them a ladder and
when they left I realized onebody in
there but I also realized if some [__]
go down my woman gonna stand with me
even if she don't know how to okay so I
do all my routine and stuff I say
goodbye cuz I ripped it the audience
going crazy I jump off stage I run right
to my car cuz these days I'm kind of
popular and in a room full of black
people I got to do 30 40 pictures for
free and I ain't down with that [__] so
I get my car go home right so when I get
to the house there's a video Waiting For
Me Stevie Wonder went on stage right
after me and he said Michael Michael
when is your wedding date and somebody
yelled out Michael already left and
Stevie said dang I want to tell him I'm
G sing a ribbon in the sky at his
wedding now I don't know if he going to
sing it but I got the goddamn tape I
played it five times on my morning show
he said [__] so if the wedding on
November 4th if he ain't there we
running the video I can tell that [__]
right now you know so so our life as you
know is blessed brother for us to make a
living making people laugh see I keep
going on stage every night telling
people that this is what our purpose and
our goal is this is what our Focus has
to be our goal has to be to stand in
front of the Lord to go to the universe
and train the universe to pay us to do
what we love to do if you get if you're
doing what you love to do even if you
break even you way ahead of the game how
you do that huh how do you how do you
train the universe to pay you well
that's it comes down to your focus okay
it's about what you what you focused on
because you it see everything is based
on your vibration so everything you're
vibrating is what the universe gives you
that's why you don't want to play around
you don't want to say negative stuff
because the vibration doesn't do the
universe doesn't do judgment the
universe just goes by what your
vibration is so if you say you want
something to happen it happens I don't
care what it is if if you really believe
in a thing and hold on to it with all
your might every day no matter what
people say you going open your hand and
see that [__] and you going to be oh my
God how this happen because the universe
its job is to mirror your reality with
your ideology so whatever you're
thinking that's people say think
positive you want something think about
it talk about it thoughts are things man
they tangible as a bottle of water and
words of thoughts magnified so once you
start thinking of thing the universe
starts vibrating on that that and it
starts showing you a way to get the
thing you want you'll see doors open
that was not there so how do you train
the universe you train the universe by
getting on your job being focused be
clear this is the thing I do this is the
thing I love this thing I believe in
this is all I want to do this all I'm
going to do you claim it to the universe
and every place you go that's all you do
and the universe wakes up to that they
wake up to that and they start seeing it
then all a sudden you see some [__] came
to you didn't see that coming or some
somebody call you like there's a system
that I created called the 15 minute a
day system and I believe that if you
spend 15 minutes a day doing anything
within three months you'll have it in a
palm of your hands I don't care you
could be 400 lbs and want to be a
ballerina now you probably not gonna get
picked up by the bashy or the American
Ballet Theater but if you starting at
400 pounds 15 minutes a day you do
something towards dancing you might
spend 15 minutes reading dance magazine
15 minutes watching video of dancers
watching plus size danc you may spend 15
minutes doing doing the five different
uh movement steps of ballet you may just
spend 15 minutes a day exercising your
big ass might exercise 15 minutes a day
trying to get your body in shape so you
could put on a Tut two for 400 pounder
but if you do anything towards it 15
minutes a day the universe is vibrating
and so more and more elements come along
within a month somebody call you girl I
hear you trying to be a ballerina you
know your big ass can't be no ballerina
but are you serious yeah you know what
my cousin she got a bunch of plus siiz
uh people at her house they come and
dance they do hip-hop dance every day
you should join them the vibration start
coming then the word the buzz gets
around now you start taking yourself
more serious now you stand in the mirror
and you do the steps of valet you do all
five of them you get used to doing what
you need to do now your body on the
universe is vibrating and rolling with
it right then you get a call one day you
know we're putting together a
plus-size uh ba ballet company and we
heard that you you want you want to do
something okay so once again you're
still 400 lb okay maybe now you're 380
but you're closer to it this is the
universe working with you helping you
pull together all the elements you need
to get what you want because you're
staying vibrating on you focusing on
that and that alone this is what I do I
don't accept no [__] this is who I am
this is what I do and the universe hears
it it gets it and it gives you
everything you want that's how you train
the universe cuz I start out just
telling jokes and having people put
money in a basket brother now I can't do
all the work I I'm on seven projects I
have four movies in the can three that's
out I got two books coming out next
month one is a children's book called
little Bobby white by a little black boy
who always wins CU he always chooses to
do the right thing and my second book is
an erotic poetry book it's called in the
wet spot blue erotica by MC butternuts
and for children as well no for children
yes and and I'm just and I'm in love
with the most incredible person in the
world these are the things that I
conjure up because you are your own
magician and you can conjure up the life
you want it's in your hands people just
keep forgetting all of your power is
within you it ain't no nothing that's
outside of you I you can go begging
people to give you a job give you money
all that [__] but the wealth is
within you so once you claim who you are
and you stand true to who you are and
what you do the elements of that will
come to you because that's the vibrat
that's the vibration you putting in the
universe you because it's all about
energy we all connected we all the same
people so we could fight and [__] act
like we ain't with each other but at the
end of the day we're all these same
thing there is no difference or distance
between us you know so that's that's
what I'm telling people pleas you go you
got to do that you got to decide okay
this is what I do chicken what I do and
that's what I do I don't do no other
[__] I'm not a vegetarian I [__] with
chickens I play with Rubber Chickens I
talking chickens the universe gonna do
some [__] you gonna look up one day and
someone gonna bag up to your house with
a 100,000 Rubber Chickens [__] y'all
doing with all these chickens well we
heard how much you love chickens Mr
cower and the guy who manufactures these
sent them to you now you change the a
put your name on it and you sell them at
$20 each I was here in Atlanta
performing one day and this guy in the
audience say I give you $20 for that
chicken I said bring the money
[__] so when he stood up his
wife said don't give him 20 give him 30
he said baby I give him 40 he walked
over hand me $4 I gave him the chicken
and he walked away and I went to the
microphone and I said I spent $486 on
that chicken and we just kept it going
so whatever you're vibrating the
universe is going to bring that to you
that's what come when bad [__] happened
to you that's what your vibrating when
you're constantly dwelling on some
negative [__] is coming to you even if
you think you trying to get rid of it
because you're dwelling on it man I
ain't G I ain't gonna never mess with
this dude no more just continue to talk
about that dude is creating that energy
of negativity that makes you not go
further you got to get rid of all the
negative [__] in your life you want to
be great really and live a happy life
oqp only quality people you got too many
[__] in your life that's still
backstabbing talking behind your back
they come to you to gossip and I I
guarantee you soon as they leave your
ass they going to gossip about your ass
to the next person they talk to all
these backstabbing lying Too Faced
[__] you know who they are get
rid of them only only positive people
around you everywhere and you'll see
your life rise just get you know who
they are some of them in your family
some of the worst [__] in your
life is a family member sometime you got
to love some people but you got to love
them from afar I love you I don't [__]
with you but I love you you know what
I'm saying I see Thanksgiving dinner
that kind of thing you know but once you
clear all that minutia all that garbage
out the way because that's what that is
negative people uh backstabs all the
[__] that's negativity that's just
garbage minutia dirt on your feet rub
that off and stay positive look at the
light stay prayed up stay connected to
Spirit stay connected to yourself we
talk try to have communications with the
higher source we need to learn have
communication with me I want to talk to
me I want to remind myself how great I
am not because I created me because God
created me he don't create no garbage
God created me so I'm not just a
comedian I'm the greatest comedian on
this planet
there's a lot of people who dispute that
but I'mma keep saying it until one day
the whole world says he's the greatest
because that's exactly how the vibratory
system works just keep saying it keep
saying it and you'll become it more and
more whatever you keep saying you're
going to be whatever you keep saying
you're gonna do is going to happen so be
careful of the words you
use so like for for this show I want
this to become like almost like the like
new Johnny Carson where it's it's a
really like a high quality talk show
where comedians can come on and find a
new audience or it can be like com who
have an audience can come on and have
like discussions here like they can't
have on any other show right so you
talking about this right now in like the
first time we've recorded in an actual
Studio setting and not in like a hotel
lobby or whatever I feel like it's
really good timing so to like build on
this positive momentum are you saying I
should be like visualizing what I want
the studio to look like visualizing who
I want on the show like absolutely and
you should run with it what's the name
of the show is it hot breath hot breath
you should run with it you got the
t-shirts yet I got the mugs you got the
Caps mugs you need all that [__]
everybody you talk to is supposed to be
by hot breath okay everything you talk I
don't care what the conversation is it
it should always come back around to hot
breath okay everything and and take it
seriously you here take it you are
Johnny Carson you don't want to be you
already are who you are you got your own
talk show and this the [__] you ain't no
different than Johnny Johnny was just a
standup comic till he got that [__] yeah
he was a good one though he was no bull
[__] n Johnny was funny he was funny and
for that era that age that you know that
age and time he was a funny cat you know
but more than that he was safe so if you
trying to be Johnny you can't have
[__] on your show like me cuz
we gonna curse and [__] to late but you
need to have you trying to be Johnny car
you better get some cleaner Comics or
make sure you have a sign the door no
cussing because that that then you re
and it does make a difference okay
because what crowd are you trying to
reach who is your audience now if your
audience is the nice ladies and stuff
and and and you want to get the the
grandmas and all them you want the
family crowd then just don't do anything
blue My Morning Show is a a f is a
family show we can't do no cussing on on
a on the morning show and we can't do
any dirty jokes can't do none of that on
that show because it's a family show
that's the audience I'm trying to reach
my podcast you can say what the [__] you
want to say and say however you want to
say it that's that but you got to know
what your audience is and when you know
who you're serving then you you lock it
down just for that I wouldn't let people
curse I wouldn't let them do that I mean
if every now I need a [__] drops in or
something like that damn that's okay
people should never use the b word on TV
and M and F and all that stuff that's
late night that's cable you know and
even if you are cable you don't have to
be like cable like you could be whatever
you want to be like I say we have the
greatest TV show on the internet that's
one of our slogans we have one of the
greatest shows on the internet I'm doing
TV on the internet people say oh you're
not doing TV you doing the interet I am
doing TV I'm doing TV but I'm doing it
on the internet I created a thing called
a gramon you know I'm currently saving
my money and building money so I could
do a one hour special on Venice where I
started it's called the king of Venice
Beach and we doing an indie go go it's
one of the ways we we're raising money
but another way is I created the gathon
which is you remember ton you kind of
young you remember Jerry Lewis's ton so
this is the same thing it's a Teton but
on Instagram so I call it a gathon I've
already done two 12 hours brother from
9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. I'm doing jokes
I'm telling stories I'm reading from my
poetry book and Comics are coming in all
just all day on Instagram comics are
popping in vocalists are singing
magicians are coming on for 12 hours
raising money I've done two I'm going to
do a third one in about a month and a
half and it's called the gathon so you
can create your world man you got all
the stuff you need and we ain't even got
all this [__] and man we've been doing
our [__] for three years man we doing
that just with a a a a laptop and and an
iPhone that's it and and we killing them
we bringing all kind of people through
so you have the show already know your
show is what you want your show to be I
already know that man you already one of
the coldest shows on TV you gotta let
them know that got people like Michael
kayen this [__] y'all rolling player
and if you just do that that's it and
and get signage up you know put up more
stuff that that reflects who you are get
things on your table that reflects who
you who you are man and create your PE
create your audience ask the people to
join you and give them a title or a name
or something you know hot breath the
breathers you know they're the the hot
breath of verse is what we call them the
hot breath of verse put that down use it
all the say it over and over so it get
it locks in people psyche and then
you're doing exactly what I'm talking
about you are preparing the universe to
pay you for what you want to do but you
the universe leads up to you to do the
work to get there that that people talk
about prayer without works is hollow and
that's true you could pray all you want
but ain't gonna just happen CU you sat
your ass there and prayed that happen
you pray and you also walk over and give
it a hand you work with it you know you
have a great look if you funny you going
to be a bad [__] I ain't Hur no
jokes I am but if you funny yeah I'm
clean too my comedy my stand Up's clean
that's perfect cuz on my show it's two
things you have to be funny and have to
be clean if you're not clean we hit a
button and knock you off before you
finish your set and if you ain't funny
oh [__] it's going to be a long walk
back to your car we going to talk about
your ass for like 10 [__] minutes we
going to tear your ass up all we going
to talk about for the next 10 minutes is
how horrible your [__] was I like one
lady told me she said well you know they
tell me I'm funny I said [__] who is
they I need you to have call me and I
need you to go back and work on your
[__] and come back in 30 days and she
came back and Tow that [__] up when she
came back cuz she you don't want to fail
in performance nothing teaches your ass
like failure when you bomb yeah what's
some of your worst bombs yeah I've never
bombed oh I've never bomb I have one
time where I almost bomb but I don't
qualify it as that one time well when
the Middle East War kicked in in like
87 I I was hired to come and do comedy
at a naval base but they had hired me
months before they didn't know the
[__] war was going to kick off so the
day I showed up was the day they was
about to deplore to the middle west and
I went up and stood there in front of
all these uniform soldiers and I I did
about four minutes of [__] that I know
was hilarious that people have laughed
at for years them [__] didn't
budge they didn't give me a smile or a
smirk they look at me when is this [__]
over and and with me there was Joan
Rivers and she came over and she said
well you are very brave to have
attempted to tell jokes to this group of
people on this day and that's what I got
out of that I got out of that you have
to know your audience you got to know
your audience you gotta bring that
material but I ain't never went on stage
and bomb telling jokes and stuff with an
audience [__] no that's not possible
that ain't gonna ever happen I'm too
funny for that [__] there's no [__]
way even if my material don't work I
know how to do crowd work I know how to
you know and that's we that's what we
talking about that we left the stuff I
learned by being on that beach being on
that beach for all those years for those
nine years with all these crowds of
people one thing I learned is improv I
improv ain't nothing you could say I
can't jump right on it with some funny
[__] or some corny [__] or something
that connects to it you know and so when
I'm doing my shows you know because I do
comedy shows I do concerts as you know
tomorrow night I'm doing um a concert
with uh Stephanie Mills and Jeffrey
Osborne when I'm do the crowd work is
what helps you there not routine you see
somebody wearing a funny hat or lady I
know you didn't choose that dress did
somebody help you pick that you know
just crowd workk but all that stuff I
got from being on Venice from people
attacking my show like I could be in the
middle of the joke and you see some gang
banging Brothers some Hood Brothers they
want to know how am I holding all these
people mostly white but white black
Asian gay Hispanic Everybody's In This
Crowd 500 people who [__] am I to be
holding them in the palm of my hand and
they come out try to mess with me but I
kill a Heckler holy [__] I come from a
small town called Fresh off a heckler's
ass and a Heckler make me homesick I
tell I make a Heckler want to commit
suicide I wish the [__] a Heckler would
come to my show with that [__] I tear
your ass up you know so but I learned it
from being out there in the middle of my
joke somebody would mess with me I had
to stop [__] them up then get right back
where I left off and so after years of
that I don't fail I don't bomb at com I
fail a lot of things but not a stand up
if I'm on the stage with or without a
microphone I'm going to kill every time
every single time that's a guarantee
well especially during red Fox's jokes
you know yeah I don't have to work red
has some of the best joke red had one
thing that was just a sentence and you
could just keep saying a sentence and
drop one word and the sentence turned
into a story oh John let's not Park here
oh John let's not Park here oh John
let's not Park oh John let's not oh John
Let's oh John oh I mean he was this
[__] was brilliant he he wrote
poetry and songs and all kind sh no it's
a it's a very rich field that we're in
as comedians it's something that I am
hum humbled and honored to be able to do
it I think it's a gift from God you know
and this is all I do I be on stage
sometime and I can't even believe and I
tell the audience this is why I know I'm
blessed cuz all I do is stand around and
say silly giggly [__] and y'all give me
money you know and that's how it really
is if you get this comedy thing down all
you have to do is walk around a planet
saying silly giggly [__] and they're
going to roll money up to you and pour
it at your feet well what what have you
learned I mean you've literally like
worked with like the best of the best
you know said a few at the beginning but
like what have you learned from being
around like just the best comedians in
the world is there like a commonality or
some traits or mindsets or habits you
picked up like what have you I don't
know and you want to be careful because
you don't want to pick up anything of
theirs because anything that looks like
is theirs they'll come for you why you
steal my [__] why you do this you I'm
the one walk like that I don't want to
talk like that so I don't I don't know
what I learned from is watching how
people car of themselves as people gotta
not not as particularly artists because
people sometime act goofy because
they're artist
but even the goofiest artists the
Charlie
Chaplain uh are brilliant that's how
they get to where they are because they
really know this [__] the Lenny bruers
they're brilliant they knew this [__]
you know and um there's a big
conversation out there now about
stealing jokes and [__] you know but
there so many conversations about coming
so they talk about stealing jokes that
dude uh Mr television Milton burrow oh
yeah Milton burrow would go to a comedy
show and sit in a front row with a
yellow pad and a pen and if he liked
your [__] he write it down and do it the
next day he a give a [__] you know so
you you have that you have that out
there you know and then there another
thing and then you have the whole thing
about how come men always got to put on
a dress to be funny what really that's
one the black community How come every
time black men want to be funny you know
Eddie Murphy and all them I can name 30
white men who got wealthy wearing
dresses in in comedy and I think Robin
Williams won Academy Award doing it I
think uh who Tootsie won Dustin Hoffman
won Academy Award for something like it
Lot Like It Hot that's uh [__] Jack
Lemon and I mean you can go on and on
with the true greats even Milton Burl
they all did what they needed to do to
be funny so that's all I want you to
remember is in the center of all of what
you're doing you're a comedian so as a
comedian your first job is to be funny
the second job is not become a preacher
they don't come for comedy to hear you
tell them what to do with their [__]
life they want to drink and they want to
laugh and if you can teach them without
preaching to them they [__] dig it
you know if they get both of them but
the main thing it's funny so if you stay
on your funny you got a platform here
brother you stay on your funny and in
invite people man don't don't be shy
don't wait till they have to be Stars
it's all kind of cold cold artists out
there who's never had an opportunity man
that's what I'm find like I said over
over 500 and something Comics over 400
of them I've never even heard of and
they funny I have maybe a 3% not funny
rate 97% of people come on to show funny
because we laugh with you it a but you
know two or three of us on air so we
laugh with you but the chat the people
putting Applause and stuff in the chat
and we throw those up so you see their
responses too and if you funny we
ringing Bells applauding and cheering
but if you
ain't we man I'm telling you don't play
now but we do I would love to have more
white artists more white comedians come
on the show just because I don't want a
black show I though I'm a black man and
I stand tall for black don't get me
wrong black people are my favorite
people in the whole white world I say in
a room full of white people I crowd I
don't give a [__] and you should feel
the same way about who you are and where
you from but I so I love black people
but I don't want a black show I want
everybody show I want anybody who thinks
they could be funny or think they can
heal the planet or think they could give
us something that lifts our lives and
makes us feel better that day come [__]
on I don't care if you got stripes and
polka dots bring your ass on the show
and so we' had some of everybody and
they perform and they sing and they
dance and they do things I wouldn't
imagine they would do for people for
free and they coming on my show working
for free so I consider that great
blessing a great honor I'm so humbled by
that and so grateful to God you know so
that's that's pretty much it I well I
can't tell you how grateful I am that
you were willing to Flying early and to
be on this show you know I can't that
just shows who you are and I even talk
about what I flew in for okay so I'm
doing Indiegogo y'all Indiegogo I am we
will link this in the description of the
show for sure oh
i n d i e g o go o i n d i e g o and
then just put in Michael Kay the king of
Venice Beach and it um video will pop up
where me go into details about who I am
what I've been through the video so
awesome you guys see the video I saw the
video did you see the video promoting it
and so we're promoting it you see who I
was the history where I've come from
what I'm doing and we're doing the
special and I need the help of the
audience you guys to help me do this I
can't do it by myself in fact you guys
can be producers so like if a person put
$100 in they can get the love packages
with my three first books now I have the
two new ones coming out but I have three
before my first book was on the greatest
president in my lifetime Barack Hussein
Obama okay it's called a Funny Thing
Happened on the Way to the White House I
knocked on the door and a brother
answered okay that's a children's book
and it's awesome I haven't moved them
like I wanted to I only moov 18,000
copies but they're pretty good all right
second my second book is my first
motivational book it's called Michael
goes motivational so I'm talking about
motivation through comedy and then my
third book is a portrait book called
Miss Innocent goes the cool school and
other silly stuff which is a portrait
book for adult children now if you put
in $100 you get the love package if you
put in a th000 you get producers credit
on the show so when the credits roll
you're listed as a producer that's right
you could produce the one hour Michael K
special live v b you tell I produced
that they say you ain't produce [__]
look at the credits look at the credits
I already have eight people who who are
doing that you could be a an associate
producer for three grand you know and
remember these people aren doing it's
called they buying something these are
people who see these Indiegogo things
and they see someone who has a dream and
they think that dream is going to help
Society because it is cu I'm giving back
to the homeless and they see that and
they say I want to help you get that and
they just give you know like one guy the
biggest thing out there was um jump what
is it called jump what's it called jump
is it jump start is a a a source of
getting money was jump start engine what
it called jumpstart I think it's called
Kickstarter kickstar it's called
kickstar a guy went on Kickstarter he
wanted $10,000 he was trying to get
10,000 cuz he has a card game called
exploding kittens and all he has is a
deck of cards with these pictures of
kittens and [__] he got $4.9 million
what from people who watched him on
there and sent money so his project his
product pull it up go online pull up
exploding kittens it's GNA blow your
[__] M so what I'm doing I don't need
for million I need 200,000 um but we can
make it with 100,000 but we need two uh
we did one what's her name we got we did
our first uh Indiegogo we got 17 GR
Grand that ain't bad we just started the
second Indi goo we do the gathon uh we
got these two women getting 10 of their
friends together and they getting almost
butt naked they going to be in bikinis
they gonna get soaked up and they going
to wash cars all day to raise money butt
naked car wash to raise money for this
project we got three girls doing making
lemonade we got three children who are
making lemonade and they carh no no
they're not the he go down the street
for that
they you been trying to get people in
trouble and [__] I A about you so so
anyway um I'm going back to Venice Beach
as he told that's I used to be out there
from 86 to 95 did 5 hours of Comedy
every Saturday and Sunday so I'm going
back to the spot where I started uh
actually right in the center of the
beach I'm GNA do one hour it's going to
be phenomenal and um also on that day
I'm giving away
1,986 goodie bags to homeless people so
it'll be bags that'll have clothing or
it'll have a way to get clothing it'll
have a cart for you to get money it'll
have toiletries and Health Care things
and we ALS also going to give a portion
of the money to the St Joseph uh Center
which is the church that's in Venice to
takes care of homeless people and they
don't just let them sleep there they
take care of their medical stuff they
they give them training it's just really
great so on that day we get to give back
plus gonna be so flat all my celebrity
friends gonna be there we gonna raise
money it's GNA be shot like you've never
seen an outdoor venue shop before I got
aerial view and everything it's going to
be flat and awardwinning you can be part
of it go to Indiegogo put in Michael
cower c o l y a r Michael cower uh and
uh the king of Venice Beach it'll tell
you the story after you watch the video
though scroll up cuz then breaks it down
it tells you what you can get in each
category you know CU we give those
things as perks we're not trying to
buyue those are just perks to say Thank
you so like we can't give under 100 but
you can send in 10 five one you can send
in 20 you can send in 47 Cent Dam it I
will accept that we'll need that for
something you know and uh but you can
put in 100,000 you put in inity somebody
could show up out the woodwork and say
Michael quit playing I'mma write this
whole thing off let's go we hope for all
of that we look for all of that but what
do we do we just put it out there
brother that's all I can't make nobody
do nothing I put it out
there between me and the chicken though
we gonna raise that money now we're
doing it in in May so when we get to May
we're doing it with whatever money we
have so I ain't got nothing but that
first 17,000 we're shooting this one
hour special and I'm shooting with
Leslie small Leslie small is one of the
coldest black
celebrated uh comedy directors uh
concert directors in La he does
everything Kevin Harts everything Cat
Williams uh everything Steve Harvey and
so this guy is so good and he's so
connected so this is going to be an
award-winning vehicle and it's going to
be so much fun it's gonna be hilarious
it's gonna help people it's gonna feed
people the king of Venice Beach
meanwhile watch me every day on YouTube
mik K Morning Show it's easy it's free
and you don't have to watch in the
morning most people don't even watch
till they come home from work like in
the morning when I do my my show and
unfortunately you don't see your numbers
I'm able to see my numbers I might have
43 people man for the show but by the
close of the evening, 1500 people have
watched the show CU they come in from
work and they go right to the TV and
pull up what did Michael do on the show
that day that's how I want your show to
be I want your show to be so that people
need to come back the next day and see
what the [__] he gonna do next you if
you gonna be regular and ordinary quit n
close all this [__] and go home if it
ain't no point of it if you're going to
be extraordinary stay where you are do
stuff they don't see coming surprise
them come in one day and talk about some
[__] they would have never thought you
talk about you know come in one day and
sit down and say I never said this
before but y'all know I'm black and then
don't say [__] look serious for about a
minute now I'm [__] with y'all man I
mean it's just it's so many ways you can
go you know y'all got two dogs down
there that's extraordinary I love those
animals come here one day with just the
dog today we just talking about the dog
and hum y'all know any dog humor yeah I
mean the thing is that you got a blank
slate here man you could a canvas you
can paint whatever you want in here man
and they're going to follow you as long
as you're true to you just be true to
you don't let nobody come telling you
the way to do it you do it your way your
way is the way for you they way is their
way go and bump it up the road do that
[__] we're doing it your way here
this your [__] and then people start
resonating then people come out to
woodwork they got to come every day I
got my people called the CIA Clan it's
about 43 of them that won't miss that
show no matter what the [__] happen no
even if I ain't there I have to run a
rerun they are there to watch instead of
cya Clan because people will come to
love you if you give them something to
love yeah well I loved our time together
today Michel I loved our time together
man you're so sharp man you got to come
do my morning show I definitely will I
definitely will and I'm talking about
right away I can get you on this next
week brother yeah let's run cuz I didn't
know you doing stand up but we're we're
unlimited brother yeah inside of you you
could do anything and everything brother
as long as you believe in it that's all
you got to do if you believe in anything
quit quit letting people tell you you
can't just hold on keep thinking it
every day this going to happen I already
see it it's done I'm already writing
checks got we doing you going to look up
and that [__] going to be knocking on
your door you say well how did you get
here and it's going to say didn't you
concentrate didn't you focus yeah train
the universe to pay you that's the way
that [__] works all them boys is doing
it doing the Cat Williams and and all
them they all that all them know it's
about the universe is taking care of
them they understand it where it comes
from you know well I I have a feeling
that after this episode we're um that
we're going to be getting paid a lot
more I'm feeling it I hope so man you
deserve it bro you look like a show host
man I would hire you sight unseen even
if you Ain open your mouth and say
nothing you already got to look that's
down but you're also sharp and pleasant
and you're a great guy I enjoy talking
to you I enjoyed talking to I'm I'm
really looking forward to you coming to
do my show Absolutely Absol thank you
man hey y'all the show is called hot
breath and you know some of y'all got
that [__] too and you need to bring your
hot breath over here and watch us when
we do it and it's funny over here and
all the top stars come here all top
comedians everybody just fly make their
way to hot breath how come you ain't
here yet what's your problem you need to
get out the mustard and catch up it's
called Hot Breath You to ask somebody
Michael CER thanks for being on hot
breath my friend it's my pleasure and my
honor sir absolutely you appreciate it
y'all take care and I'll be good to you
wooo wooy woo